事情是这样子的，
就是我们结婚11年了，
有一个一个儿子一个女儿，
然后呢，
我们在小县城，
自己白手起家嘛，
然后有有套房，
有个车，
就很非常非常普通的这种生活就是靠自己嘛，
就前两天我发现就他出十多天就被我发现了，
然后呢，
嗯，
他对我平时对我还不错，
他跟那个女的他俩在一起十多天就被你发现了，
他俩认认识多长时间呢，
认识也就。
个把月吧，
然后呢，
他平时他所有的收入都在我这儿，
然后对家庭也还不错，
就是责任心啊什么的都还不错，
后来我发现了之后呢，
他就求我原谅，
就给他机会，
我还在犹豫的时候，
发现这个事情没有这么简单啊，
我就发现这个她不是我要不要原谅他的问题是这个这个女的她非要不顾一切的让他来跟我分手，
然后要跟她在一起，
然后呢，
她也是跟她的老公。
三少呢，
已经提出了，
我现在搞不懂她是图什么，
就是他们的条件，
她自己老公的条件可能比你老公条件还好一点，
是不是不是好一点，
是好太多了，
他能有孩子吗？
你就啊，
孩子多大了呢？
跟我的差不多吧，
就几岁了，
几岁啊，
你现在啊，
其实这一段关系当中最关键的点在于哪里啊，
对，
关键的我在于你老公的态度现在是什么样子的，
他向我表达的态度是他他跟他在一起几天之后，
就发现这个人很极端，
恰想结束这个，
他的意思就是大概最开始就是想玩玩嘛，
可能没有想那么多，
然后呢，
就就想着，
嗯，
你也有家庭，
我也有家庭，
可能就不会影响对方，
对吧，
然后结果没想到几天之后呢，
就发现这不是这么简单，
然后可能就就不想在一起了吧，
然后好像就感觉就甩不掉了，
甩不掉了之后呢，
感觉12天被我发现，
我感觉哈，
对是这个女的故意必须好像要让我发现知道吧，
我就搞不懂他现在这个她在想什么，
而且他不就逼我老公来找我嘛，
然后本来我还在考虑，
我来帮他捋一下啊，
现在我你们整个家庭最大的风险点，
你记住了，
现在对你们整个家庭最大的风险点在。
为什么对你老公怎么能够证明自己不知道对方的老公的身份，
就是说你老公现在不管他用什么方法录音也好，
干嘛也好，
一定要想一种方法能够去拿出证据，
证明他跟这个女人在一起的时候，
是不知道这个女人的老公的职业以及现状的，
这样的话，
你们整个家庭的风险才能够平安落地。
记住啊，
这个证据一定要你老公一定要动脑子，
不管是通过聊天的记录也好吧，
了天的记录说哎呀，
我跟你认识的时候真的不知道啊，
你老公是干什么的呀，
现在对吧，
我了解到你老公的情况，
我觉得你老公比我好太多了呀，
觉得你老公比我太优秀了呀，
我自己也觉得我们不太合适，
你可能刚开始跟我在一起是新鲜，
我还是不如你老公，
反正总之不管你通过聊天记录也好，
通过录音也好，
你们整个家庭的风险点，
现在最关键的点就在这个事情上，
其他的都好说，
我还想咨询一下，
就是这个事情，
如果是那个了，
他不会受到制裁吧？
为这事儿我还真没有研究过，
因为我本人没有接触过这方面的案例。
就这个事儿的话，
可能得问一个形事的律师才能问明白，
但你老公肯定如果他知道啊，
如果他明知他这么干的话，
他肯定会，
我现在考虑的不是不是什么情感问题了，
我现在是考虑的是为了于我的孩子，
我的家庭，
我这个降低这个伤害点的问题了，
你现在最需要做的就是和你老公把这件事情证据给固定下来，
保存好，
能救你老公一下，
然后至于说现在假设能够趁着你老公需要你的帮助，
需要你的配合，
对吧，
需要你共同来保护家庭的时候，
如果可以跟你签一个夫妻财产约定书，
对吧，
家里面的财产分一分，
会一下你的利益，
那就更好了，
这个倒没有，
这个他一开始就说了，
如果不原谅他的话，
他会净身出户的，
这个我相信他，
我跟你讲啊，
就说事态的发展，
不是说你现在相信谁的问题，
那我问你，
你是不是以前也相信他不会在外面乱乱找人，
你要趁着他现在有害怕，
有内疚，
你先保护好自己和儿女的利益，
同时还能保护家庭，
与此同时顺带着救一救他，
明白吗？
抓紧时间，
这两件事情啊，
第一件事情怎么能够让你老公逃脱，
或者说避免牢狱之灾，
就是我刚刚讲的那个点，
就是跟他认识的时候。
她那个亲密关系的时候，
是不知道她老公是现意的，
不知道老公的具体职业，
不知道她老公是干什么的，
就能保住你老公别吃牢饭了啊，
然后第2个点呢，
就是保护你和孩子的财产，
那么第3个点，
如果说对方是属于性格特别极端的话，
那么你们现在做的每一件事情啊，
就记住了啊，
做的每一件事情你们都要留一个正确思维，
什么叫证据思维呢？
万一那个女的哪天她自激了，
她错了，
她干嘛干嘛了，
也找不出你们两口子的毛病，
不要有什么跟他刺激的话呀，
或者说怎么怎么样的话呀，
对你，
对你性格极端的人来说的话，
一方面是怕他伤害你们，
另一方面是怕他伤害我，
我觉得他就有这方面的倾向啊，
然后你们就遭遇我，
好吧，
好的，
嗯，
就这样啊。